[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to with spider-man far from home
just around the corner major plot leaks
in regards to the movie have started
coming out so I thought I'd break down
one of the big ones that we have on the
film that goes into major depth on many
of the scenes in the movie and it's
ending this one differs slightly from an
earlier released one which predominantly
was just made up of a handful of bullet
points so it seems far more legitimate
and trustworthy this is full spoilers
ahead so if you don't want to have
anything about the movie potentially
ruin for yourself then I highly
recommend that you turn off now this is
an Internet leak so do take it with a
grain of salt as it may not be accurate
but as we saw with my Avengers end game
and Game of Thrones leaks both were
pretty much 100 percent accurate so I
don't want to spoil the movie for anyone
who doesn't want to know so this is your
last last last chance to back out we
still here good well with that out the
way I just want to give a huge thank you
for clicking this video I hope you enjoy
it and now sit back relax and let's get
into my leaked plot breakdown of
spider-man far from home okay so the
movie opens immediately after Avengers
and came with Peter and may and happy
Hogan flying home on a private jet after
just attending Tony Stark's funeral
everyone is pretty bummed out about it
with Peter crying but happy States that
Tony sacrificed himself because he knew
there were other people that could
continue to fight and he states that the
character thought highly of Peter and
that if he wanted anyone to be his
successor that it would have been him
actually wrote the script for this on
the 24th of May at 8 a.m. as you can see
in the bottom corner of the video here
which is way before the trailer draft
that actually confirmed this so again it
kind of backs up that the sneak is right
anyway they land and go their separate
ways and Aunt May reminds Peter that
they have a charity gala that night and
she kinda reiterate to a happy set about
Peter taking
Tony's position as a protector and that
he trusted Peter to be there for the
people that he couldn't she then
jokingly says you don't need to be Iron
Man but you do need to be spider-man
tonight which ties into the nighttime
event honestly at this point this all
seems really believable and from the
backup of the trailer it seems the kind
of tone that they would be taking with
the private jet scene only really being
able to take place here it's at this
point that Peter realizes there's a
thing between Aunt May and happy and as
we saw in the trailer he's ghosting Nick
Fury and the character goes out on his
nightly patrols after telling the police
that he's going on vacation he goes to
see the Iron Man Monument and decides
that he's not really cut out for this
life which is similar to the spider-man
op that we saw in the comics when Peter
left his costume in a dumpster whilst
this already happened in spider-man 2 a
Marvel probably don't want to just
repeat that scene Peter decides to go on
holiday and leaves his spider-man suit
behind which both literally and
figuratively shows that he doesn't want
to continue with the mantle and may
however does still pack it we then cut
to some Eastern European shady-looking
characters who say that their time has
come and that the spider will finally
meet its end this kind of ties into the
whole multiverse thing and as these
aren't villains that we've seen
spider-man encounter before in this
universe you can bet that they'll be
from some other earth where he followed
their plans they're kind of cloaked in
darkness but it plays into the movie
later which I'll get into from here we
cut to the first day in Venice and it's
clear that MJ and Peter are getting
pretty close Ned also remarks that their
flight was one of the first out as the
world is finally getting back on track
and I can't believe one of his friends
from high school is a model now and in
college this kind of pays lip service to
many of the questions that people had at
the end of endgame with pretty much most
of the class being vanished except a
select few
anyway they watch a news report and see
Mysterio fighting a monster over Tower
Bridge in London they remark that he
must be a new Avenger as they've never
seen him before and we get a full-screen
scene of Mysterio fighting the Beast cut
to Peter going back to his room which is
when Nick Fury shoots Ned in the neck
and tries to recruit Peter Peter tries
to come up with excuses with the last
one being I don't have a suit to which
fury replies now he definitely all out
of excuses Nick takes him to a secret
shield base which is where he meets
Mysterio and Maria
for the first time and we learned that
the former is apparently from another
dimension
Maria tries explaining it but Peter
butts in saying that he knows all about
string theory the multiverse and more
which is a nice little character B
Mysterio and Peter team up and go to
Germany to fight the next elemental
compete realizes that Mysterio is way
way way more powerful in years and the
ends are pretty much having to play
defensive for the majority of the fight
as he gets his butt kicked but some
reason Peter just can't seem to fight
the monsters whereas Mysterio is landing
hit after hit and ultimately ends up
saving the day together the two go at
the bar that we've seen from the
trailers and Peter who's really lost all
of his confidence at this point asks how
Mysterio can do it he can't Mysterio
replies because he's from another
dimension and he knows all of the tricks
and has more control from here on out
Mysterio sort of becomes a mentor to
beat her at this point and he explains
that if he doesn't want the
responsibility of being a hero then he
shouldn't be one there are other people
that can do it now and this further adds
doubt into Peters mind
Mysterio batters up by saying because he
has loved ones Peter will always be at
risk of hurting them and that you should
leave it to people like himself who
don't have anything to lose just as this
happens the lava monster attacks a theme
park where MJ and Ned and the rest of
the gang are at MJ almost dies in it's
at this point that Peter realizes
something is up here because his web
pulls a metal panel of the elemental an
AC circuitry beneath it Peter wants to
get to the bottom of it so he uses the
black stealth suit and the red and blue
one which Aunt May packed to make a
brand new black and red suit and with
the circuitry he got from the elemental
he figures out a way to stop them just
as this is happening MJ comes in and
asks if he wants his offer walk
Peter tries to tell her how he feels but
MJ stops him and tells him that she
knows he's spider-man Peter says that he
doesn't want to be any longer but
there's something that he has to do
which MJ replies sure there is your
spider-man go get him tiger
Peter tries to track down Mysterio which
is when Peters spider sense goes wild he
turns around to see Nick Fury and he
tries to tell Matt something's up with
Mysterio
however fury just stands there silent
and his face begins to change which is
when we see that he's actually
Belem chameleon which ties back to the
Eastern European scene chameleon has
been rumored to be in his phone for a
while so it definitely ties in with
other leaks that we've heard he's one of
my favorite spider-man villains and I
absolutely love the classic rock where
he disguises himself as Jay jonah
Jameson so it's great to see that the
villain could be included in the MCU
he tells Peter that you'll pay for what
he's done to his family and then the
vulture Mysterio and Scorpion step
forward and begin kicking the crap out
of him Peter realizes though that these
are probably illusions and he uses the
circuitry from the elementals to change
them into Captain America and Iron Man
with their new AI they begin fighting
back against Mysterio and chameleons and
they're just completely wail on them I'm
not sure how accurate this is I don't
know how soon that Marvel would be
willing to bring the characters back
after they both just depart the series
but I guess we'll see Peter gives Tony a
really heartfelt goodbye and the AI says
that he's proud of him and all that he's
accomplished from here Peter frees the
real Nick Fury and returns to New York
he takes the illusion equipment that
gave him the Tony Stark message and
stares at it for a bit
deciding to smash it as he's no longer
bound to living a fantasy world and he's
willing to accept that he must become a
hero we then cut to the credits and we
see the Avenger tower which has been
renovated to become Oscorp tower this
has been pretty widely reported on in
all of the leaks so I definitely think
it will happen and it's smart way to
bring the Osbourne's into the universe
as they've been missed out and that's
the entire leak to me it makes a hell of
a lot of sense going off the trailers
and things like the black being combined
with the red and blue suit to make a new
one seems legit so I can really see this
all happening it's a heavily detailed
leak and I can see it being legitimate
and if this is the case then it sounds
like it's going to be a brilliant movie
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the plot leaked and whether you think
it's legitimate or not comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my ending explained breakdown
a bright burn which would be linked at
the end we've also just launched a merge
section on the channel so if you want to
support the show and get something back
from it make sure you click the links in
the boxes below this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like
it's a
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]